hi I'm Dan Morrill with Google developer
programs I bet by now you've seen the
application demos that we've posted
online and I hope you're as excited by
them as we are but if you're a developer
you know there's more to it than just a
fancy demo it has to be easy to build
those applications as well and that's
what I'm here today to show you I'm
going to build an application for
Android using nothing but the tools that
are included in our SDK let's get
started the first thing we have to do is
create a new project see i'm using
eclipse
and to create the project I just go to
file project and the project I'm going
to create as an Android project the
project name can be whatever you want in
this case I'm going to call it hello
Android the package name I am today
entering as comm Google Android hello
but of course that's in our company's
namespace and you should feel free to
use whatever name space is appropriate
for your organization the activity name
is going to be Hello Android as well the
application name is the human readable
name of your application and this is
what will appear in the title bar and
window and so on so once we've entered
that data we go ahead and click finish
and there's our application what did
this create well if you look in the tree
over here you'll see that we have a
source directory including the file
hello Android Java this is the entry
point file to the application this is
the class that Android runs when you
start the application let's build an
application that knows how to dial the
phone specifically let's build an
application that lists everyone in my
contact list lets me scroll around
choose one and then when I select it
goes ahead and dials that phone number
let's see how that's built the first
thing that we want to do is check out
this file over here called main dot XML
in the layout directory this file is
what we refer to as an XML based layout
so in this file as you can see right now
it has only a single text view that just
displays some hello world text so the
first thing we want to do is change that
text so that it no longer says hello
world and instead has this label instead
called
name then we're going to copy that
because we want two of these and then
once we've copied that we're going to
move down a little bit and paste it and
now we've got two copies
for the second copy we're going to
remove this text because we don't want
it to have fixed text in this case we
want it to have an ID instead because
we're going to refer to the ID from our
source code and so there we are now
we've got our XML based layout file the
first thing that we need to do is come
up here to the hello Android class
currently it implements or extends the
class activity we actually need it to
extend a different class called list
activity list activity is a convenient
subclass that really just says I'm going
to display a list orient information and
it's got a whole bunch of useful methods
that we can take advantage of for this
application so that we don't have to
write them ourselves the first thing
that we're going to do is get access to
some data the Android way of doing that
is to use what's known as a content
provider we get access to the content
provider system via this method call
here and what that does is it lets us
issue a query in this case we're
querying the system for the entire list
of contacts that are available on the
phone in response we get a cursor the
cursor is what we use to actually access
specific data from the query that we
requested now we have to tell the UI
exactly what we want to display because
of course the contact list consists of a
lot more than just say a first name and
a phone number it might also have an
email address or a mobile phone number
and a home phone number and so on so
what we're going to do is create a
mapping and the mapping tells us which
column or name in the content provider
that we want to map to which UI element
and so in this specific case we want to
say people name which is to say the
person's name gets mapped to the entry
that we called row entry in our XML
layout and so just to refresh your
memory I'll switch back to that file and
show you right here you can see that we
have an ID that we could be that we
created and called row entry and then we
call this method set list adapter and
the list adapter itself is an instance
of another class called simple cursor
adapter and that's a class that really
has all the smarts and all the logic in
it to make use of the mapping that we
just declared so to summarize this
method real quick first we get the data
then we map the data from the data
source to the user interface then we
create a class that knows how to
actually accomplish that mapping and
then we set that to be our current
adapter once we've done that that will
display things in other words it'll show
us a list of all our contacts but what
it won't do is it won't let us click on
any of them to click on them we have to
come over here and do one last thing we
need to go to the source and then
override a method the method that we
want to override is down here towards
the bottom and it's called
on list item click click ok and there
we've got a method body what this method
does is this is the method that's called
every time the user actually clicks
something in the user interface in this
specific case we want it to dial the
phone and so the first thing that we
need to do is create a class called
intent in an intent is really a columns
kind of a generic concept what it means
is it's a reflection of an applications
intention to perform some activity so I
create an intent object and I say that
the specific activity that I wanted to
perform is call action which means dial
the phone obviously I need to tell it
what number to dial and so I go to the
cursor that I got from the content
provider I query the adapter for the
specific row that the user clicked on I
extract a little bit of data from it I
set that data on the intent so that now
the intent knows what it's supposed to
do and then finally I call this method
startactivity so when we call
startactivity that's will actually cause
the dialer to appear on the screen and
initiate the phone call but certain
operations that the device supports such
as dialing the phone and accessing the
users contact list are protected and the
user needs to grant permission before an
application can access them and so we
have to request that permission via our
Android manifest so if we come over here
and double-click on this Android
manifest file you'll see that there's
already in here a definition of what the
contents of our application are which is
what Android manifest does it's sort of
the traffic cop of your application it
specifies its contents as well as what
it does so what we need to do is add two
lines to this
the first line that we need to add is a
request for a permission called read
contacts this permission if the user
chooses to grant it will allow the
application to access the users contact
list similarly we also need to create a
request a permission called call phone
and what that will do is is request that
the user allow this application to dial
the phone so now that we've done that we
go ahead and save that file and if we
come back up here and run the
application again then hey there we are
as you can see it contains all the
entries in my contact list and hey let's
style my wife
well it's an emulator so it's not
actually going to do anything but that
is how it works so this is a
surprisingly sophisticated example for
the number of lines of code that we've
done and throughout the entire
application framework we've really tried
to make it this easy to use and I think
that as you you know explore Android
you'll find it to be very easy and
pleasant to develop for I hope that
you've enjoyed this and I hope that you
think this was time well spent I thank
you for your time
and I hope to see you online